hello everyone welcome to our webinar
today
on applications of flow and imaging
cytometry
to covert 19 research my name is kamla
thiagrajan
and i'm director of flow cytometry
assays and
at luminex corporation during this
presentation
my colleague dr haley pugsley and i will
share
how our flow psychometry and imaging
technologies at luminex
can be utilized in aspects of kovin 19
research
the rapid spread of covet 19 has created
an
acute scientific need to understand
clinical manifestations
and mechanisms of the disease and also
understanding
how to monitor and tackle the disease
intense research is ongoing worldwide
at the molecular protein and cellular
levels
and luminex provides a variety of
solutions in all these approaches
in this presentation we will mainly
focus on covid19 research
enabled by cytometry
major uh questions on poet 19 research
by cytometry can span how does the virus
impact the immune system how does the
immune system respond to the virus
viral entry mechanism and what drug or
strategies can be identified
to modulate the virus if we look at
areas of viral impact on the immune
system
numerous studies are being published on
what is ongoing with the immune cells
and different stages of infection and
if they can provide clues and predictors
about the infection
as to how mild and or severe the disease
diseases
select few examples are indicated on the
right
and some of these early studies have
found some key markers
many have identified a pattern where the
t
cell absolute counts the cd4 and the cd8
counts and blood from covid19 patients
are drastically diminished in response
to severe infection
and further some of these populations
also seem to recover
as the patient recovers so see
phenotyping of blood samples
with regard to absolute counts and
percentage is critical
and in many cases people are performing
tb
and lymphocyte analysis as well as
evaluating t cell differentiation into
knife
and memory subtype many studies are also
identifying markers of inflammation for
example
inflammatory monocytes are have
significant morphological and functional
changes with co-19
infection and have been shown to be
involved
in proper in progression of the disease
several studies are demonstrating the
importance of tsl
exhaustion markers such as tim3 and pd1
as well as increased cd8 expression
and t cell activation marker
along with impacts on the immune cell
populations people are also studying the
immune response
mechanisms and several very interesting
publications of late
have shown study details where pbmcs are
stimulated with viral antigens
and the consequent impact on the immune
cells are being evaluated
these kind of studies not only
characterize the immune cell response
but also
look at secreted cytokines and
intracellular cytokine measurements
are also being performed and these kind
of approaches are again very important
and
vaccine development strategies as well
as drug development approaches
another big area of research a study is
evaluating viral entry
and infection mechanisms people are
interested in
how the virus is interacting with
certain cell types uh they are creating
in vitro model to understand
uh the viral mode of entry and infection
uh to understand what kind of protein
and expression markers are involved
and how these are impacted by viral
binding and
infection and drug screening and
repurposing studies
are also being extensively performed to
identify
effective antiviral strategies by taking
where people
are taking existing approved drugs
and then applying them to viral
infectivity studies and several papers
discussed in the these approaches as
shown on the right
at luminex we offer a range of platforms
and solutions
that can enable cytometry and provide
information in kobit 19 research
these include our platforms based on
microcapillary
cytometry such as the guava mu cell
analyzer and the guava side platforms
are shown on the left
and our range of imaging flow
psychometry platforms
which combine the power of imaging along
with flow cytometry
and can provide unique insights into
studies such as inflammatory
mechanisms of covid19s during this talk
i will be mainly focusing on
microcapillary flow cytometry
and my colleague dr haley pugsley will
will discuss imaging flow cytometry
so let's first take a look at what we
mean
by microcapillary cytometry
microcapillary cytometry which is shown
on your left
differs from traditional flow cytometry
on the right
shown on your right that it in in that
it does not utilize sheet fluid and
instead
the sample is aspirated directly from a
tube or a valve
through a microcapillary flow cell and
interrogated by a laser
and data is collected from detection
channels as it flows through
the simplification of fluidics results
in a more compact system
and these which are easy to operate and
need minimal maintenance
microcapillary cytometry gives rise to
some distinct advantages
first because of the nature of the
technology and the use of a precision
pop
we can get absolute cell count
information
without having to add external beads and
this capability to get absolute cons
automatically brings benefits in many
application
types the design leads to small
cellular samples being needed for
analysis and this can be very valuable
in cover 19 research where researchers
are trying to maximize the information
from precious samples available the lack
of sheath fluid
also leads to low biohazardous waste
generation
which is again highly advantageous when
dealing with
infectious samples so let's take a
closer look
at our two platforms based on
microcapillary cytometry
the guava mu system and the guava easy
size system both of which
are based on microcapillary cytometry
so the guava news cell analyzer is an
easy to use simple and compact
instrument for cell analysis
the instrument uses a 532 nanometer
laser
and provides information based on
forward scatter
and true fluorescence detection channel
the platform has a very small footprint
and is portable
and can easily fit anywhere even in the
biological hood
and this is an aspect that can be very
helpful
as studies are performed on kobit 19
samples
where people might want the instruments
inside the hood
or proximal to it the platform
is based on microscopic cytometry that
we just discussed
and this provides the advantages of
absolute counts and percentages
as well as needing small samples and
generating
low waste one of the key features of the
instrument is the intuitive touch screen
interface
um which guides the user through the
steps
and makes the acquisition and analysis
very easy
there there are a whole range of
dedicated kits for the platform
along with asi specific software modules
which allow a variety of experiments to
be performed
and quantitative cellular data to be
obtained at the single cell
level there is also an open module
a software module available on the
platform which
is allows the user great flexibility in
terms of the experiments that they want
to perform
kits on the platform range from areas of
cell health
immunology to cell signaling and thus
spanning broad application areas
so so copenhagen research can um
often require quick screening and
characterization of blood and pvnc
samples so the acids of the mutes which
can be really
valuable in this kind of work are are
assays such as
news content viability essay and the
immunology assays both these assay types
are very
simple to perform no wash assays
and using dedicated reagent sets
which have been well validated you can
quickly obtain
information on pbmcs or blood samples
so let's take a look closer look at the
muse
content viability assay this is a very
useful assay
for determining cellular concentrations
and viability status in a cellular
sample
and this assay has been extensively
applied
to a wide variety of cell lines um and
many studies have been performed
comparing
uh this assay with different methods
um the assay is accompanied by a
dedicated software module
and can provide summarized data outputs
as shown on the
left in an easy format for the user to
deduce
the results and the next steps
in this slide we show examples of
applications
of the assays to the study of pbmcs
as shown on the right plot we can really
obtain a very good wide
measurement range with a nice linear
response
with either fresh or frozen pvmc samples
the assay provides for very good
precision
and a low percent cv is achievable for
both count and viability results as
shown on the table on your left
so the assay can thus provide
very important viability or
concentration assessment of pbmc
samples which is important if you're
planning on immune response studies
or evaluating status of your sample
or pre-screening your samples for in
broader study
the immune immunology assays are
powerful as
is that uh provide a lot of
very valuable information on t and b
cells in blood or pbmc samples
there are specific separate assays for
cd4 t
cell cd8 t cell and b a b cell
determination
and each assay provides absolute count
for the populations
total lymphocyte counts and population
percentages based on total lymphocytes
the assays employ no wash protocols and
the easy-to-use instrument
delivers accurate reliable results this
combination
of the protocol as well as analysis
allows for very high precision as can be
seen
on the data table on the right and
where in interoperative studies very low
percent cvs were obtained across
multiple operators on multiple
instruments analyzing
the same samples
so we've also compared the results
obtained the muse immunology kits
with other platforms and in this example
we're showing you the results from the
new cd4 t-cell assay
um the results obtained on the muse for
a wide variety of
whole blood samples was compared against
results
uh from a higher end flow cytometer
and what we see based on this data set
is that we are really getting very nice
correspondences
very nice correlations and slopes for
the measurements
of total lymphocyte counts cd4 t cell
absolute count as well as cd4
percentages of lymphocytes
and all of this can be obtained using
only 10 microliter of blood
per sample
the mu system analysis can also help in
other aspects of kovin 19 research such
as in drug repurposing study
and here we show an example of looking
at
anti-malarial drugs on the left plot
three different anti-malarials are
compared for the ability to reduce
plasmodium fasciparum infection of red
blood cells
using the muse rbc invasion assay
and you can see the comparative potency
of these drugs at the different
concentrations
now when these same drugs are applied to
other cell types and this
you can see on the right when these same
drugs were applied to jerket cells
and apoptosis was studied using the
immune xn5 and densely assay
you don't notice other effects in that
drugs such as atomosome for example
start
showing significant apoptosis even at
low concentrations of the drug and this
could be
desirable or undesirable depending on
your strategies
i'd like to now move on to another of
our microcapillary-based platforms
the guava eugenside systems
these system pack a lot of analytical
power in a very compact format
both single loader systems and
um which are called the user side single
loader systems
and high throughput systems the hd
systems are available
which can do samples and tubes or 96
valve formats
and still fit into a hood
the systems are based on microcapillary
cytometry
and enabling small samples
sizes and absolute counts and low waste
several instrument options are available
for these platforms
ranging from one to three lasers and up
to 14 detection channels
so enrich multi-parametric data can be
easily obtained on the system
in addition insight software shown on
the right
allows for powerful data comparisons
with its easy compensation and analysis
features
heat maps that allow for quick
identification and even the generation
of 560 and ec50 curves within the
software
the easy size systems does provide a
really nice platform for enterage
multi-plyometric analysis along with the
advantages of microcapillary cytometry
so with the bava eside systems the
capability to do multiparametric
immune cell analysis is enhanced and one
can really do some
nice tb and ksl analysis with low sample
volumes
um so here we show an example of
staining
cd checks plus mcd checks with low blood
control
with a combination of cd45 3 4
8 38 19 and 56 antibodies
results for the absolute count and
percentages of
lymphocyte outputs are compared to the
vendor provided limit for the sample on
the right
uh on the plot sensor are shown in the
right the upper
panel providing the absolute count
comparison and the lower
panel uh provider providing the percent
positive cell comparison and what you
can see
is that you can get a quick verification
of the performance
in terms of identifying and correctly
and accurately quantifying these
populations
um and as i mentioned this kind of
immunophenotyping can be obtained with
just 10 microliters of whole blood
in a norwash assay of a plate orientose
we've done more extensive studies where
we've applied
similar strategies to stain uh you know
a large number of blood samples
compared results here the uh uh
you know blood samples were stained with
cd3 four and eight
uh and the results were compared
with our platforms that utilized ibd
methods and
reagents our data demonstrates very nice
correspondence
and cd4 absolute counts determination
uh showing nice correlation coefficients
as well as slopes and the comparison
one can also perform more detail
analysis
um here for example uh the system was
utilized
for dissecting nine memory t-cell
sub-populations
um and um you know uh this is an
eight-color staining
performed in a no-wash format with
identification
of cd4 and cd8 t cells
and then further differentiating them
with
using cd45ra and cd62l markers to
identify
memory and knives subsets
again absolute counts and percentages of
these populations can be obtained
and this is very valuable in covert 19
research
another area of cobit 19 research is the
search
for effective antiviral compounds or
drugs
several recent papers have looked into
strategies
on different cell lines on how known or
new antiviral compounds
modulate viral activities using
cytotoxicity assays
the guava is aside hd system with a
splat-based screening
and multi-parametric apoptosis assays
and inside software can be very valuable
in these cytos toxicity studies and i
can show you
one such example um
so here we show you some examples of a
multi-parametric
assay um which is the micro damage
assays
the micro damage assay provides
information on three parameters
simultaneously
mitochondrial potential an xn5 based
apoptosis
and cell deaths the dot plots show you
the simultaneous changes in these
populations
uh on whether there's both you know
mitochondrial change and an x
and five um r and x and five
and so that so the plots give you really
very detailed comprehensive
information um below
in the two graphs we show you the
application
of such an assay to treatment with two
different compounds
etaphyside and starosporin where joker
cells were treated with different doses
and the impact on
all three parameters with a single assay
can be studied
and what we notice in both cases is
there's no impact on cell death
but there is significant depolarization
and apoptosis taking place
um and more significantly in the
treatment condition with startup foreign
where you can see both there's a lot of
depolarization
and annexin by based apoptosis detection
so these kind of assays can thus give
highly enriched information
to the user in a single experiment in
distinguishing impacts
and they may help speed up compound
identification or drug
repurposing strategies and provide a
deeper understanding of the type of in
facts
in these drug studies
to summarize kobit 19 research
requires the assessment of blood and
cellular parameters
for understanding disease mechanisms the
immune response
and research on drugs or compounds that
modulate viral activity
here we've shown here that the simple
low-cost guava mu cell analyzer
provides several two color assays for
the simplified determination of pbmc
concentrations for the characterization
of cd4 t cells
cd8 t cells and b cells and whole blood
or pbmc
samples a range of apoptosis assays on
this platform can also provide valuable
information
in compound or drug studies
the guava easy site systems which use
microcapillary
psychometry allow for multi-parametric
tube
or plate-based analysis um more complex
immunophenotyping data and multiplex
apoptosis assays can be easily performed
on the system
and provide highly enriched information
to researchers
who are engaged in various dimensions of
covert 19
research with that i'd like to now hand
this over to my colleague dr haley
perksley for the next part of the
presentation
thank you